- I know this is getting
lost in the shuffle
of all the crazy things that are happening
in the wake of the Capitol riots,
but it's important to not
lose sight of the fact
that President Trump committed
another impeachable offense
with respect to the
Georgia election results.
We learned recently that
one of the U.S. attorneys
for one of the federal districts
in Georgia resigned amid pressure
from President Trump to
find more election fraud.
Byung J. Pak, who was the U.S. attorney
for one of the federal districts resigned
rather than comply with
the President's pressure
to engage in election fraud.
Now I've already called
the totally improper call
between President Trump
and Secretary of State Brad Raffensperger,
but this alone in and of itself
is also just as bad and
just as impeachable.
So let's not lose sight of that as well.
Stay tuned for more
legal election coverage,
and as always, I'll see you in court.